,
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING MARWARI]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING IRISH]
SPEAKER 3: [SPEAKING BENGALI]
SPEAKER 4: [SPEAKING URDU]
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING HEBREW]
SPEAKER 6: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 7: [SPEAKING ST. LUCIAN
CREOLE FRENCH]
SPEAKER 8: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
SPEAKER 9: [SPEAKING KONKANI]
SPEAKER 10: [SPEAKING NEPALI]
SPEAKER 11: [SPEAKING DANISH]
SPEAKER 12: [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
SPEAKER 13: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SPEAKER 14: [SPEAKING HINDI]
SPEAKER 15: [SPEAKING ARABIC]
SPEAKER 16:
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
SPEAKER 17: [SPEAKING CANTONESE]
SPEAKER 18: [SPEAKING FARSI]
SPEAKER 19: [SPEAKING MARATHI]
SPEAKER 20: [SPEAKING KLINGON]
SPEAKER 21: [SPEAKING KASHMIRI]
SPEAKER 22: [SPEAKING GREEK]
SPEAKER 23: [SPEAKING GERMAN]
SPEAKER 24: [SPEAKING TAMIL]
SPEAKER 25: [SPEAKING DOTHRAKI]
SPEAKER 26: [SPEAKING POLISH]
SPEAKER 27: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
SPEAKER 28: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
SPEAKER 29: [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALL: Happy new year!
[MUSIC - "AULD LANG SYNE"]